so so so let's talk about this uh in
2016 we'll talk about
uh the question is should donald trump
get another four years
and so he he you so trump uh we go wait
we have this sorry i'll just jump to the
article and then i'll get to my point
quote it is statistically impossible
that i lost white house releases
46-minute address address by trump
complaining that he lost the election
and pleading with the supreme court to
overturn biden's victory
they say the president posted a
46-minute video he complained about
voting machines and bouts that came in
election night
predicted what he was saying will be
demeaned and disparaged
said he didn't want a re-vote but wanted
to overturn the election immediately
he called the election a total
catastrophe trump said it may be the
most important speech i've ever made
in 2016 coming off of the obama
administration
man i was just so like i don't even care
this
is you know this stuff is going to keep
happening it was bush now it's obama
what is it going to be hillary trump
whatever they said hillary was going to
win i didn't care i'm not gonna vote
because i didn't see trump as being
particularly better
when trump got in for the first about
two and a half years or more i mean he
was upping drone strikes there were
commando raids in yemen
there were civilians dying and i was
like here we go again
59 missile strikes into into syria but
something started to change
later on he fires john bolton he starts
saying the american people don't like
this
we're going to get our troops out of
syria we learned that
there were officials u.s federal
officials who lied to the american
people and donald trump to keep our
soldiers
in syria that's insane donald trump was
elected
to to end the forever wars partly he
didn't do a good job
initially he started to improve so i
decided you know i'm going to vote for
the guy now
the question is knowing what we're going
to get with joe biden
what we'll first talk about should trump
get another four years
then we'll talk about the fraud
accusations the things he brought up and
and your thoughts luke well you brought
up a very good point especially with
what donald trump was promising because
when he was running
to be president of the united states one
of the main ways he galvanized
so many people is by saying he's
anti-war he wants to bring the troops
home
everyone rallied behind that everyone
was excited about that
it was it wasn't just hope and change
but we also have to understand barack
obama
campaigned on those same things
promising
bring back the troops stop the spying
stop the torture
george w bush same thing promised to be
a non-interventionist
and look at him starting the iraq war so
with everything that's kind of moving
forward it really makes you wonder
is the u.s president that that powerful
i know it's a very kind of symbolic kind
of gesture but when we look at
everything kind of moving forward
we're definitely putting ourselves in a
very peculiar situation
that's not an easy one to figure out so
how we're going to move forward
it it's it's really going to be
something that uh i'm i
i can't figure out we're going but do
you think trump did a good job in the
past couple of years
did he do a better job i i think he
definitely did
i think i was i was definitely
entertained by by his rhetoric
uh but but i think he he fell short i
think there's still a lot of individuals
like julian assange that would say that
he did a very terrible job since
many of his policies led julian assange
many of his actions let julian assange
to still be
in in you know jail right now extradited
assange should be and snowden should be
parted and i think personally ross
ulbricht should be uh pardoned
as well and you know if i was donald
trump right now
if if i was him if i was in charge i
would keep all the promises i made i
would send all the troops home i would
end the war on drugs
but but hold on but i would still try to
do it
at least on pen and paper right so then
when joe biden comes in
he has to authorize them he has to
convince the american people saying
no we need the war on drugs no we need
uh julian assange that we need
the troops this is this is why you know
donald trump
there's a lot of there's a lot of
lefties hate the man and i was i was
surprised i thought one of the one of
the possible
outcomes of the of the 2020 election
would be that progressives would be like
i don't know i'll take the anti-war guy
over biden but nope nope
they came out they said they wanted
biden because a lot of these people are
young and don't know
like we had we had one guy on he was in
a teenager during occupy wall street he
didn't know anything about this stuff so
what we end up happening what we're
going to end up seeing now
is joe biden is going to get in and he's
going to reverse
a lot of populist policies that the left
probably does like
he's going to go nuts on war we're
counting down the days i love it
i'm looking at these anti-trump reply
guys who all of a sudden are anti-biden
they're i'm like oh here you go you
screamed about trump maybe these people
are just contrarians yeah now you may
wolf just realized oh there's going to
be more lockdowns yeah i didn't want to
vote for this
and people don't understand i mean some
people say biden's not there
he he he maybe isn't but we have to
understand he still is a front porch
front person for the military industrial
complex for the pharma industrial
complex for the prison industrial
complex
all big businesses all the corrupt
institutions all the multinational
corporations
are behind him joe biden just says
whatever talking points
he's assigned to and he's been doing
that his entire career you look at the
issues
whether it's segregation if it was
popular he said it oh he was for it but
not even
not even when it was popular when it was
the status quo and the establishment
approved
those talking points so whatever the
establishment wants he is the front
person of that
and he didn't even have to promise to
bring all the troops home
he didn't have to promise what barack
obama had to promise what
what donald trump promised he didn't
even have to do that so that's something
that really should should wake people up
to what's coming in the next four years
because
he's not even promising to be a good guy
he's he's not even doing
press releases he's not even doing press
conferences he's not even speaking to
the people
he's just this mystery weird guy who uh
mumbles
is donald trump the greatest president
of your life your lifetime
ah he's i i think you have to say yes
man
politicians we're comparing him to other
presidents i gotta say
he is substantially better than every
president i've lived through politicians
are like
i'm i can't curse here are like buttocks
uh
they're all full full of crap but some
of them have a better diet
yes donald trump at least with his
rhetoric at least with some of his
nationalistic
kind of policies is a lot better he was
able to shake things up he was able to
rattle things
and and that i will give him credit for
when it comes to julian assange when it
comes to some of his foreign policy
i have very serious questions about he
called himself a patriot and a globalist
and i think his presidency exemplifies
that he said
himself yes he said i am quasi i forgot
the exact
terminology and wording i could actually
look it up here uh but he said he he
compared himself a globalist and a
patriot
trump did yes interesting uh which which
is what he's been he's kind of been
flip-flopping
where he's hanging out with henry
kissinger one day and the second day
going after china and their trade
policies
when you have kissinger the guy who
literally opened up china to the world
if you look at the conundrum that
america and the world is facing with
china
those have the direct fingerprints of
henry kissinger
david yeah well well fired this
larger kind of institution part of the
advisory board for the pentagon which is
now
on his way out i know and i'm like so so
here's what a lot of people are
questioning
why is trump making all of these moves
like replacing the pentagon leadership
sending uh his acting secretary of
defense says special forces now
answers directly to me and bypasses a
bureaucracy then he gets rid of this
advisory board when i when
someone sent me a message they were like
trump fired kissinger i was like what
and i looked it up i started laughing it
was yeah
you sent me that article i'm like wait
what do you mean what yeah
and you know the guy's still kicking the
guy still
such you know didn't he like call for
genocide before or something
well when you look at his policies that
he was able to establish under nixon
under the vietnam war specifically in
cambodia specifically
in chile specifically in third world
countries where
he was the kind of architect and an
engineer of this
larger term of an economic hitman so if
you look at john perkins and
the economic hit man and the revelations
that came out of that book
it's henry kissinger all over it the
world bank the imf the same
organizations calling for a global reset
now
were some of the same institutions that
were hand in hand working with kissinger
working with the united states working
with the cia intelligence agencies
overthrowing governments
setting policies all around the world
and when you see
a lot of the detrimental horrible things
that have happened
whether it's war whether it's
multinational corporations abusing lying
poisoning or doing anything
a lot of them point back to directly
those kind of individuals
that need to be called out so here's the
crazy thing right you know during occupy
wall street you had the left protesting
obama
in 2016 the left didn't show up to
protest the rnc they showed the protest
the dnc
now for some reason they voted for for
for biden i guess
but what's going to happen now is going
to be so weird because
i was they were like tim poole's a
leftist the whole time like during obama
and everything
then donald trump's elected and i'm like
the media is lying about it but the
leftists align themselves the
establishment so then also people start
calling me conservative
now i'm telling you when i start ragging
on biden i've been ragging on biden
my friends i've racked on obama and
biden endlessly for the past decade okay
now they're going to be like what's
going to happen
who's going to be left who's going to be
right yeah what's the right wing it
doesn't matter anymore
i rag on everyone because i think they
all deserve to be ragged on
uh anyone in power i believe in total
decentralization that's my own kind of
philosophy but i i think there's a you
know a statement from donald trump
that's really going to be poignant here
with what you were just saying when he
said
antifa is going to have their way with
joe biden they're going to eat him for
breakfast did he say have their way
it's not an exact quote i'm ad-libbing
here i don't have the exact words but
generally he said that anti-fuzz is
going to you know take down joe biden
and i
i you know right now we're not seeing a
lot of anti-fog
protesting a lot of the stronger
government restrictions and lockdowns
uh they're pro lockdown yeah weirdly
which is they're like we're
we stopped fascism yay okay government
now what oh you want us to be forced to
stay in our homes
yay we defeated fascism yes we want
checkpoints yes you want us to shut down
all the private
and small businesses to help out walmart
and amazon it's absolutely
exactly right we want to talk about what
fascism is yeah but
mussolini said the merger between the
corporation and the state for you know
for the mutual benefit or whatever
thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you